my
aphasia is a
disorder of language
so it's a disruption to the language
system
so it can affect people's ability to
produce language and or their ability to
understand language aphasia certainly is
something that changes your life we rely
so much on
communicating with others
[Music]
most common causes of aphasia are
strokes there are of course other causes
anything that can damage the brain
depending on where the damage is can
result in aphasia can affect the
language system
so it could be a hedge trauma it could
be a neurodegenerative disease it could
be brain surgery depending on where it
takes place in the brain any of these
things
could affect the part of the brain that
is responsible for language and produce
aphasia
[Music]
[Music]
it could be very disruptive for bruce
willis himself in terms of communicating
with others and not being able to find
the words
to express himself
and it could be very
challenging for the people around him
around bruce willis in terms of them not
being sure what it is that he's thinking
or what he's trying to communicate to
them or whether he's you know whether
he's still himself
[Music]
you